♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE NOTICED
SOMETHING INTERESTING RECENTLY
WE TRY TO PAY ATTENTION THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF SIGNIFICANT
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY LIKE PASTORS IN ARIZONA
AND NEW HAMPSHIRE FOR EXAMPLE.
WHO SEEM TO OF BEEN DEFUNDED BY
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN
WASHINGTON.
WHY IS THAT CUSTOMER SUMMING IS
GOING ON HERE.
THEY MIGHT KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE HE IS THE CEO OF AMERICAN
MAJORITY HE JOINED JUSTIN I
THINK SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
MAYBE I'M JUST BEING PARANOID,
I'M NOT SURE YOU CAN BE TOO
PARANOID AT THIS POINT BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF THE
CANDIDATES WHO WERE CHALLENGING
THE MOST BASIC ORTHODOXIES OF
WASHINGTON WHICH AREN'T USUALLY
SHARED BY THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS, PEOPLE ACTUALLY MAKE
THIS A REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT
ARE GETTING SHAFTED BY THE
FUNDERS IN D.C. IS THIS
HAPPENING?
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY HAPPENING
MITCH McCONNELL THE CENTER
LEADERSHIP JUST PULLED
$8 MILLION WORTH OF ADS OUT OF
ARIZONA.
AND TUCKER I REMIND PEOPLE IN
THE POLL THAT JUST CAME OUT
RECENTLY SHOWS THEM DOWN BY TWO
POINTS.
AGAINST MARKEL HAS ONLY A 47%
IT'S A WINNABLE RACE AND THINK
WHAT THE REASONS WHY THE DOING A
SUPER BEING THE G.O.P.
ESTABLISHED MEANT IS NOT PUTTING
AMERICA FIRST.
IT'S WASHINGTON FIRST IN AMERICA
MAY BE EVENTUALLY.
YOU LOOK AT THIS BEHAVIOR IS BY
SOCIOPATHS.
YOU CAN ONLY LOOK AT THIS, MITCH
McCONNELL WOULD MUCH RATHER
LOSE RACES THAT HAVE AMERICA
FIRST SENATORS IN THE SENATE
BECAUSE HE'S PETTY, HE'S
VINDICTIVE AND HE DESPISES THE
BASE.
THAT'S THE ONLY EXPLANATION THE
REAL EXPLANATION AS TO WHY HE'S
PULLING FUNDING FOR BLAKE
MASTERS AND OTHER.
HE WOULD PREFER TO BE IN THE
MINORITY, HE IS PLAYING GAMES,
TUCKER LET'S BE HONEST HE'S
PLAYING GAMES WITH THE FUTURE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
BECAUSE HE IS PETTY AND
VINDICTIVE.
>> Tucker: MITCH McCONNELL'S
FAMILY HAS BENEFITED GREATLY TO
ITS TIES FROM CHINA, COMMUNIST
CHINA.
MAYBE IT WOULDN'T BE A GOOD
THING TO HAVE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE HORRIBLY ANTI-CHINA
MAKES A SUMMING LIKE THAT OUT
LOUD BECAUSE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
SAY THAT.
>> IT'S A PROBLEM YOU DON'T WANT
AMERICA FIRST IN SIDE THE
AMERICAN CAUCUS BECOMES UNRULY
MIGHT BE NOT BE ABLE TO CONTROL.
AFTER THIS MANY TIMES TUCKER AND
ASSAYED AGAIN.
MITCH McCONNELL IS A SMALL
ENOUGH INDIVIDUAL THAT WHEN PUSH
COMES TO SHOVE ALL HE REALLY
CARES ABOUT HIS BEING A LEADER
OF THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS EVEN IF
HE IS IN THE MINORITY.
IT'S ALL MITCH McCONNELL CARES
ABOUT HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
BEING EARLY IN THE MAJORITY.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY, HE WANTS TO BE THE
LEADER OF THE SENATE AND IF HE
HAS AMERICA FIRST CENTER INSIDE
OF THAT IT BECOMES PROBLEMATIC
FORM.
THEREFORE I WILL PULL FUNDING
FROM 8 MILLION WORTH FROM BLAKE
MASTERS AND OTHER FUNDING FROM
OTHER AMERICA FIRST TYPES
BECAUSE I'D MUCH RATHER THEY
LOSE THEN WENT BACK AND CAUSE
FOR ME AND WASHINGTON, D.C.,
EVEN IF IT MEANS I'M IN THE
MAJORITY.
>> Tucker: I HOPE THAT
PATRIOTIC AMERICANS CAN MAKE UP
THAT DEFICIT AND GET HIM TO THE
AMERICAN'S AND I HOP